Germany says it has foiled a far-right
plot to overthrow the government 25
people including a soldier and a judge
were detained after police raided 130
sites across Germany one Russian
national is also among the detainees the
so-called Iraq citizens were allegedly
preparing to force their way into the
parliament well for more on this I'm now
joined by Dominic Kane who is in Berlin
and this seems like a massive police
operation what more can you tell us
this is a very large police operation
involving thousands of officers the 25
people arrested we know about the
suggestion also that there are 50 people
of interest to the authorities insofar
as this operation is concerned the
interesting thing this movement the
reisberger as they call themselves well
they are people who believe that the
modern manifestation of Germany is not
one that they consider legitimate they
would like to see a return to the
Germany that existed prior to the end of
world war one
insofar as what we know well we know
that these people were in some cases
heavily armed that they were former
soldiers some of them from the army of
modern Germany posts the end of the Cold
War some from the former East Germany
there is some speculation that a former
member of the bundestag that's the
parliament of the building behind me may
have been involved in this although it
hasn't been confirmed by independent
sources we know also that there's going
to to be a news conference given by the
federal prosecutors in karlsler in
Western Germany in the course of the
next few hours they say around 13 GMT
where we can hope to find out more
information about those who have been
arrested those who are of interest to
the authorities
at its heart it is suggested that these
people have believed that there is some
kind of deep State operating in Germany
which is antithetical to Germany's
interests and that this Russian national
with others who have been who are
amongst those arrested may have tried to
approach the Russian Federation for some
assistance it is not known what sort of
contact they had what happened from
those contacts if indeed they happened
lots of questions about what the
authorities have announced what we know
for a fact 25 people are arrested around
50 people are of interest to the
authorities thousands of people involved
of police involved in this 11 different
federal states have seen raids taking
place and this is clearly an ongoing
operation thank you very much there's
Dominic came for us in Berlin